[Music]
Dixon this is
Granger what are you doing get control
of alpha now L down meac needed seven
murders on Scottish soil we need to
visit the Bas in Wood
you but you're okay with it but I'm not
you for another two months and you put
me on this keys in love with
Yan nobody tells the truth there either
somebody told him what we were doing
here find out who we're all suspects yes
of course we are need to kick her out
down hey you asking me if I did this why
were you there those drones are tools
for repression my dad didn't do anything
wrong police be where you are what
evidence do you even have I have enough
you should try to complete your work
quickly they are lying to
you look
come come home I
can't